now where is Larry our octopus how do
our model and our view connect to each
other well let's think about what things
happen in our app and maybe we can sort
this out so first of all the app loads
up we start with a blank screen first
the list gets created then the ListView
populates with cats Larry the octopus
does both of these things now not for
rendering it on the screen that's the
job of this particular view but our
octopus is what tells this view to
render itself in the first place in
other words the octopus gets things
going then the octopus changes the
current cat in our model current cat
gets set to this first cat when that
happens the octopus says hey go ahead
and render this view here and then the
current cat view gets rendered now again
the rendering of this view here is not
the responsibility of Larry but Larry
the octopus does tell that view wind to
render so now the octopus has gotten our
model started gotten our views started
and everything has gotten rendered now
let's talk about the case where the user
clicks on a cat well the octopus is
keeping track of where you click so if
you click on this cat here the octopus
will run a method which increases this
counter first in the model and then in
the view now if a user clicks on a cat
up here let's say on this second one
here then the octopus does the following
things first
it changes the model the current cat is
now being set to purr and then it tells
the view over here to re-render itself
so to recount when the app loads up
first Larry initializes the model now in
this case we just have simple data so
that doesn't mean very much then Larry
tells all of the views to render
themselves and finally our octopus says
whenever you click on any of these
things do this particular or that
particular piece of functionality and
then tell the respective views that have
changed to re-render themselves